merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
mini chers collègues c'est amendement
donc comme les précédents je le présente
résolument quoi qu'un événement puisque
je crois que vous avez décidé comment
dire de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par la combinaison de
toutes les procédures il faut le dire
que vous offre la constitution de
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laisserions la retraite des
Français entre les mains des droites
coalisées mais nous ne sommes pas dupe
la journée du même nom est lointaine
dans l'histoire on ne la refera pas et
les Français non plus nous ne lâcherons
rien nous ne les lâcherons pas cet
amendement consiste à rajouter après le
mot décret les mots conseils d'état de
façon
à permettre qu'à minima le Conseil
d'État soit saisi du projet que son avis
recueilli permette une consultation des
organismes dans la vie souhaitée merci
de votre attention alors la vie de la
commission précisant historiquement que
la journée des dupes s'est déroulée ici
vos rapporteurs ne sont pas non plus
dévitalisés et ils ont donné un avis
défavorable sur ce type d'abonnement
répétitif toujours
identique d'une redoutable utilité qui
consiste à proposer que le décret soit
fixé par le Conseil d'État donc avis
défavorable
[Musique]